[Music]
hi stillwater
hello carl
what are you doing
tree pose
i'm a tree too
yes you are
in yoga we do it like this foot pressed
against the inner thigh
hands pressed together
very nice
now breathe in and out slowly
it's hard
it does take some practice
try putting your hands down here in
front of your chest
that's easier
are you practicing
yoga no we're practicing bing trees
tree pose is yoga carl
oh
now put your leg out and stretch your
arms wide this is called tipping star
why are you all standing on one leg
because we're tippy stars it's called
yoga
i've done yoga
can you do this one
very good downward facing dog michael
hmm
this pose can re-center our focus now
if we move our bodies like this
we're in upward facing dog
breathe in
breathe out
would you like to try cat cow next
what's a cat cow
i know that one cat cow
oh i get it cat cow
breathe in
breathe out
now follow along with me
cobra
breathe in
breathe out
lunge
breathe in
[Music]
breathe out
airplane
breathe in
breathe out
happy baby
breathe in
breathe out
[Music]
shavasana
breathe in
breathe out
[Music]
you